nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using
45 percent less water but with a stream
of water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15
off go to nebia.com pacman and use the
code pacman
joe biden today is going to be making
some of the biggest foreign policy news
really in a long time as far as the
united states is concerned
joe biden will be withdrawing all u.s
troops from afghanistan starting
very soon and to be completed by
september 11th of this year the
washington post can now
report that will be 20 years to the day
since the 9 11 2001 attacks uh joe biden
who we were told by
donald trump and even by some on the
left would
start wars was some kind of bloodthirsty
warmonger would never bring
troops home would send more troops to
more places
joe biden is going to do what george w
bush
barack obama and donald trump could not
do
or at least did not do now i know that
some of you will be saying well hold on
a second it was going to happen may 1st
now it's going to be september 11.
that's that's a delay what's going on
uh remember the backstory of that uh the
trump administration
negotiated a may first deadline
with the taliban last year when joe
biden
came into office he did something that i
think is generally smart he came in and
said
he didn't say because the trump
administration was so incompetent in
every way but
joe biden came in and said i'm going to
review all ongoing projects and their
associated timelines and dates
i'm pausing and reviewing before
committing
to either doing the thing donald trump
started to do or not
this included pausing and evaluating the
may 1st
plan there were things about the may 1st
plan
that were real question marks including
how exactly would the withdrawal be done
who has been uh coordinated with in
terms of this withdrawal
and the the sort of cynical
interpretation from some
was biden is pausing the may first
withdrawal because he doesn't really
want to leave
he wants to stay forever he may even
send more troops
in this particular case and we evaluate
other cases on their merits in this
particular case
it appears that joe biden really was
just skeptical that donald trump did
anything right and he wanted to evaluate
this plan for himself
as a result it won't be may but it's
going to be september it will take
four extra months i'd rather biden do it
competently
and have it take four more months than
simply do it the way trump planned
likely incompetently much like
everything else that donald trump did
now in terms of numbers officially there
are 2 500 u.s
troops left in afghanistan the real
number
is more like 3 500 there are also seven
thousand foreign forces
mostly nato troops we don't
know exactly what happens with those
other troops at this point in time but
joe biden will be holding
um a public event today it may have
already happened by the time you listen
to today's show or watch this clip where
maybe he will
outline that importantly joe biden's
plan for withdrawal from afghanistan
is not conditions based we are simply
getting out and a senior administration
official
said to the washington post that a
conditions-based
plan would be a quote recipe for staying
forever in afghanistan that would be
very bad
the u.s is going to draw down to zero by
september 11th
regardless of conditions now we've
previously
said or asked the question how far does
american responsibility
go in places where we enter
and things break the us military goes in
things break and then we are responsible
at least to some degree you break it you
bought it as sort of the general idea
how long
do you have to stay until you can say
well we
now we are getting out even if it's not
totally fixed there's very
varied opinions about this and and much
validity in different ways
joe biden has made a decision that the
limit is september 11
2021 of course we will believe it if and
when it happens
but this has been trillions of dollars
hundreds of thousands dead
millions certainly affected by it it is
time to go
trump promised it he couldn't get it
done during his presidency
biden is at least apparently going to do
it now what will the trump supporters
say
uh they seemed to support it when it was
donald trump who announced that this is
what he was going to be doing
they should still support it i can't
imagine they would now be rooting i
don't know for the taliban or for
whoever
uh if they supported it happening when
it was trump that announced it
you would imagine if they were
consistent they would support it now as
well
some are already saying that september
11th is too soon though
now how does that make sense if may 1st
was okay
how does taking four extra months make
it
too soon you'd have to ask them now some
practical questions
will afghanistan destabilize
after u.s troops leave we don't know it
it's possible that that will happen
will iran get more involved maybe in
fact
iran getting involved could be sort of
part of restructuring and getting back
to the iran nuclear deal we don't know
yet that's another possibility
it's premature to assume that al qaeda
simply rises again
or that the islamic state rises again
the taliban
is very opposed to the islamic state al
qaeda has a little presence
sure al qaeda could try to regroup in
afghanistan but there are easier places
at this point for al qaeda to try to
regroup
so what we know for now is the date is
september 11
2021 let's see if the phase drawdown
starts and let's see if we are out
in what is essentially just under five
months from today
but this is a good decision and it is a
major foreign policy decision
let's keep talking a little bit about
foreign policy one other joe biden
foreign policy
note joe biden did have a call phone
call
with russian president vladimir putin
and
i'm going to say this in a particular
way but i'm not necessarily attaching
value judgment to it joe biden stood up
to vladimir putin during this phone call
in a way that donald trump never did now
that doesn't mean
we're cheering for joe biden to go to
war with russia we're not
uh this doesn't mean we are cheering for
joe biden to be unnecessarily
hostile or adversarial with vladimir
putin
um this is it almost shouldn't even be a
big deal that this is how joe biden
managed the phone call with vladimir
putin
it's just not the way donald trump
operated donald trump was
enamored by and deferred to
various authoritarian leaders around the
world we now have a readout from the
white house and we will look at it
together this was released yesterday
it reads president joseph r biden jr
spoke today with president vladimir
putin of russia
they discussed a number of regional and
global issues including the intent of
the united states and russia
to pursue a strategic stability dialogue
on a range of armed
arms control and emerging security
issues building on the
extension of the new start treaty
president biden also made clear that the
united states will act
firmly in defense of its national
natural national
interests in response to russia's
actions such as cyber intrusions
and election interference specifically
referring to
the cyber intrusions that we know russia
was involved in recently
and the election interference that we
know russia attempted recently
the readout goes on to say president
biden emphasized the united states
unwavering commitment
to ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
the president voiced our concerns over
the sudden russian military build-up in
occupied crimea on ukraine's borders
and called on russia to de-escalate
tensions
president biden reaffirmed his goal of
building a stable
and predictable relationship with russia
consistent with u.s interests
and proposed a summit meeting in a third
country in the coming months
uh this is you know it's not a big
deal in that this is how most presidents
deal with other adversaries who we know
have geopolitical ambitions that may be
at a conflict with those of the united
states
it's not about picking a side it's
we have countries nation states exist
we have multinational collaboration
we have treaties we have agreements and
we expect
our leaders to look out for the best
interests of our country
that's it and that's already more than
donald trump ever did
biden released the content of the call
uh
nobody ate the notes i mean remember
when i'm talking about that
there was the story of um omarosa
who uh said that she walked in on donald
trump
eating paper after a meeting with
michael cohen
in what she believed was an effort to
destroy sensitive information
okay that's the reference with eating
paper
unlike the previous administration the
fact that we have this readout
also means that the entire transcript of
this call is available
to intelligence members that have the
appropriate clearance and access
as opposed to never being created as was
the case
with some of donald trump's
conversations with vladimir putin
so everything is being managed in a
completely different way
it's not about we want war with russia
it's not about militarism
we just want a president that's firm and
isn't obviously
railroaded by every authoritarian
autocrat that he talks to
and seems taken with remember trump
displeased with angela merkel
uh displeased with uh for a period of
time theresa may
displeased with justin trudeau and
emmanuel macron are traditional allies
but taken by putin's shows of strength
impressed by kim jong-un
it's it was very very backwards and so
this is
without nobody's rallying for war you
know there's going to be some on
the revolutionary left who will
say that a commentary like mine
is beating drums of war against russia
or arguing for hostility we're not doing
any of those things
it's simply a president who is able to
be cordial
but firm in a phone call with another
world leader it's a president who's not
so impressed with himself that he's even
having the conversation
and is just able to be railroaded and
bamboozled by anyone it's just a
president who understands geopolitics
and understands how you deal with these
situations so
i think there's a lot of good signs here
of joe biden in the last 24 hours
firm with putin in a phone call saying
we are getting out of afghanistan there
is a date
certain we're getting out on september
11th 2021
these are good signs geopolitically in
terms of foreign policy from joe biden
doesn't mean he's going to do everything
right doesn't mean we'll agree with
everything he does but certainly much of
the fear-mongering
from uh from the right and some on the
left as well
about joe biden's gonna invade everybody
and expand our presence and it does not
seem to be what he's doing for the time
being and that's a good thing i'm glad
to see that
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative showerhead it uses only about
half the water that other showerheads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different
experience than any other shower head
i've used i can get in and out of the
shower way quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get completely
rinsed off
so i was actually amazed that it's only
using about half
as much water nebia also offers a number
of shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia dot com slash
pacman and use code pacman will get 15
percent off
all nebia products remember that we are
mostly
a viewer and listener supported program
you can get
your membership in mere moments
at joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code better21 if you would like
for a really big discount it's almost
like the discount's so big it's
embarrassing so i won't even say the
percentage but
you can use it if you want that code is
better21
at joinpakman.com i realized yesterday
that it's not just some on the left who
would rather not hear anymore about
donald trump
it's also some on the right some actual
trumpists who simply want us to forget
about the things that donald trump did
on the left many people are just sick of
donald trump and that's
understandable many on the left want
there to never be another donald trump
in power and i'm with you 100 but as
i've said before
pretending that donald trump doesn't
still at least for now
control the republican party would be
factually inaccurate it would not be
based in reality we would do ourselves a
disservice by not
recognizing that but there's another
side to this arwel mandawi
wrote a really good piece in the
guardian called trump's enablers
want us to forget what they did we can't
let that happen
and in this article arwa accurately
points out
listen donald trump made 1.6 billion
dollars
personally during his four years as
president his
family profited handsomely from the
presidency
i could list the individual atrocities
for hours you know suggesting the
injection of bleach to treat kovid
lying about him separating himself from
his businesses
on and on and on but arwa points out
something really important which is that
by ignoring these horrible people when
they leave
office we have already allowed many of
them
to at least partially successfully
rehabilitate their images
and the perception of their time in
office john boehner is an example
john boehner now has a memoir where he
criticizes george w
bush and he's now doing some lobbying
for cannabis legalization and there are
people
who are now starting to see john boehner
less unfavorably or more favorably than
they once did
but john boehner admits that actually he
voted for donald trump
he enabled lots of the things that he
criticizes george w bush for
he shouldn't be allowed to rehabilitate
himself
george w bush himself who now appears on
ellen degeneres's show is friends with
ellen
paints his paintings and all this stuff
he was a horrifying war criminal
yes he was notably and cartoonishly
he was slightly less notably and
cartoonishly unhinged than trump
but he was absolutely and completely
horrible
and what happens as arwa madawi points
out
is that when you start ignoring them
because they're gone and you're happy
that they're gone which is
understandable that part makes sense uh
they start publishing the memoirs to
rewrite history
they become known for the best or the
most
benign elements of their past rather
than the absolutely
disgusting and monumental things that
they did you sort of
need quite frankly a continued narrative
about their atrocities to prevent that
rehabilitation
from happening and that is how we get to
the trumpists don't want trump
remembered for inciting the january 6th
riots for his total failure on
coronavirus
for the disastrous response to the
puerto rican hurricane
giving classified information to foreign
officials
including a russian spy recruiter in the
oval office
for his love affairs with various
authoritarians around the world as we
talked about earlier on in the show
you may have already forgotten about
some of these things and it's only been
a few months
trump demonized immigrants but so did
george w bush do people remember that
is that part of the narrative or has
bush successfully rehabilitated himself
enough where we no longer think about
that
there is a sort of straight line as arwa
writes
from all of these people as i've said
before and i talked about on monday you
can go
you know reagan gingrich bush
trump and with many others in between so
the right also has an interest in
defining how trump is remembered
or not remembered and that's another
part of the reason why
we can't allow the absurdity and the
insanity
to be forgotten and um where
trump is different in the sense that
he's you know a different age out of
office he's older out of office than
some others have been
he seems less aware
in a particular way of how to
rehabilitate
his image it may be a different thing
but it's important to remember that as
much as
we are glad trump is gone the right has
a significant interest
even potentially so that trump can run
again in 2024
in us forgetting what donald trump was
important not to forget it
tucker carlson this week in a completely
confused and nonsensical
monologue that maybe uh
said that maybe the reason coveted
precautions are still in place in some
states now remember some states have
eliminated all covet guidelines
but tucker says we have vaccines now
if we still have coveted precautions in
some states
maybe the vaccines don't actually work
this is tucker take a look at the clip
the federal health authorities also
recommend that you continue to wear your
mask when you go outside
how long will this continue well
according to yahoo news experts say it's
quote
not entirely clear when it will be
considered okay for people
who are fully vaccinated to stop wearing
masks
at some point no one's asking this but
everyone should be what is this about
if vaccines work why are vaccinated
people still banned
from living normal lives honestly what's
the answer to that it doesn't make any
sense at all if the vaccine is effective
there is no reason for people who have
received the vaccine
to wear masks or avoid physical contact
so maybe it doesn't work and they're
simply not telling you
that well you hate to think that
especially if you've gotten
two shots but what's the other potential
explanation we can't think of one
we know the prime minister of canada has
decided after thinking about it a lot
that vaccines just don't work and we
know that because he said it out loud
now there is a lot to say about that and
and i'm going to say it
in a little bit but in response to that
segment
dr anthony fauci appeared on cnn and
was asked about it and he slammed it
as a typical crazy conspiracy
theory take a listen to this that's just
a typical crazy conspiracy
theory why would we not tell people if
it doesn't work look at the data
the data are overwhelming in the three
vaccines that have been approved
for use in an emergency use
authorization
the j j the pfizer and the
moderna you had thirty thousand forty
four thousand
and forty thousand people in a clinical
trial with an
overwhelming signal of efficacy so i
don't have any idea what he's talking
about so i don't actually know the best
way to deal with this quite frankly
because um
if you believe tucker when tucker says
maybe the vaccines don't work does dr
fauci
going on cnn and calling it a conspiracy
theory change your mind like if you're
in the um under the umbrella of people
who believe tucker when he says it or
does it just reinforce your belief
now there is an answer there is an
explanation and it's really very simple
we have vaccines that work really well
they are over 90 effective at preventing
infection
they are almost 100 effective at
preventing
serious illness and death there's one
amazing study
of seven hundred thousand vaccinated
people somewhere on the west coast i
don't remember
if it was washington or oregon seven
hundred thousand vaccinated people were
followed
about a hundred got the virus that's
point
zero one percent
0.014 percent of the vaccinated group
got the virus
three people died that's 4.28
times 10 to the negative fourth power
go back to middle school math
to realize how tiny a number that is
these are
extraordinarily effective vaccines so
why do why does anybody need precautions
why do we need any masks why do we need
anything
because as of april 13th only 37 percent
of the country was vaccinated
it's that simple you know that the when
what we've seen
from israel is that when you get to at
least
50 55 fully vaccinated
then you start to see cases go down very
very quickly
and so if on the first day of
vaccination
you open everything you don't have
enough protection
tons of people will get the virus and
many of them will die what's really
amazing
about what tucker does is he brings up
questions that have really simple
answers
but he pretends that they are profound
and incisive questions
and his audience sees it and says wow
yeah i mean if the vaccines work why do
we have any precautions
since we have vaccines and precautions
maybe the vaccine doesn't actually work
well no
the answer is really simple barely a
third of the country has been vaccinated
that's it
that's the answer and sometimes the
answer being so simple
actually uh makes it more difficult to
explain it or convince people because
people
don't want to believe that they might
not understand such a simple answer
many people when presented with the
question we have vaccines but we have
guidelines
maybe the vaccines don't work maybe
there's this this is a lie or that's a
lie no
we just haven't vaccinated enough people
lots of people don't want to believe
about themselves
that they could have missed such a
simple
basic rudimentary answer look at the
numbers in israel
israel is now highly vaccinated they
have about 200 cases a day
israel and new jersey have basically the
same population
size they're both around 9 million new
jersey has 4 000 cases per day i'm going
to say that again because it's
it's so incredible israel and new jersey
are about the same
size and they're about the same
population
new jersey has 4 000 cases per day
israel has 200. what's the difference
the difference
is new jersey is only 26 fully
vaccinated
whereas israel i don't even know at this
point what the numbers are but it's very
very high it's got to be approaching
i don't even i mean it's got to be
between 70 and 90 percent i'm not sure
they've been vaccinating like crazy
that's the explanation and when tucker
carlson you know at this point i mean
dangerous is an understatement for
tucker carlson's uh rhetoric at this
point in time
the white nationalists are loving what
tucker carlson is doing on his show
including his rant about replacement
earlier this week which we covered
yesterday
the anti-vaxxers are loving it um those
against any covid precautions are loving
it
he is really playing to with his
populist rhetoric
he is actually playing to some of the
worst elements
of american society so the difference is
vaccination
the vaccines work we've only vaccinated
in the 30s percent mid-30s percent of
the american population that's it folks
that's the answer we'll have more about
this on our instagram page find us on
instagram
at david pakman show the number one
funding source for the david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join p a k m a n dot com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
we are continuing to learn more about
the i was going to say the investigation
but
the multiple investigations into
republican congressman
matt gates and it is every day of
becoming clearer and clearer
how serious this is we learned today
that matt gates's iphone has been seized
by federal agents but not recently
it actually was seized some time ago
this has been going on for a while this
is very very serious
the huffington post reporting new
reports
on the federal sex trafficking
investigation into congressman matt
gates republican of florida
have revealed more details about the
extent of the probe including the
seizure
of his iphone by federal agents over the
winter
and an associate's cooperation against
him since last
year gates cell phone was seized when
federal agents
executed a search warrant citing
interviews with three people
who were told of the matter by the
congressman politico was able to report
this
the congressman uh changed his number
late last year his former girlfriend's
phone
was also reportedly seized in another
development
indicating gate's intensifying
predicament predicament
gates associate joel greenberg has
reportedly been providing information
since last year to investigators
according to the new york times
so that's another piece where we learned
i guess it was late last week that joel
greenberg
was now working with investigators the
new york times has now learned that joel
greenberg has actually been working with
investigators for some time
joel greenberg's lawyer was asked last
week
did your client joel greenberg introduce
matt gates to underage girls
and uh there was not a no from joel
greenberg's attorney
although he didn't answer much one way
or the other
greenberg has said to investigators he
and gates
had sexual encounters with women in
exchange for cash and gifts
um the investigation of course is now
becoming increasingly public but it has
been taking place for some time
the justice department is also said to
be investigating greenberg's and gates's
involvement
with multiple women who were recruited
online for sex
in exchange for cash payments as a
reminder the huffington post article
notes it was previously reported
greenberg was
likely on the verge of cooperating with
prosecutors
at this point in time it is abundantly
clear
there is also a cnn report about the
details
of these uh very i mean
anything involving gate i call it
strange because gates
is involved um but without going into
too many details that are maybe not
relevant from the standpoint of politics
uh party-goers and attendees at some of
these strange events have talked about
how
they would often show up at an event
with
matt gates and there would be cocaine
and ecstasy and sex and all sorts of
different things
and of course none of these things
individually
are really the issue the bigger picture
here
is the idea that there was some kind of
cash for sex prosecution across state
lines
including with minors that's really
where the bulk of this issue is
we don't even really know at this point
all of the other possible crimes that
maybe may be part of this
but the investigation is ongoing and
it's not looking particularly good for
matt gates
now it was reported late last week uh
that matt gates had hired
one of donald trump's various attorneys
to represent him um i don't know that a
trump attorney is really going to cut it
given the the depth of what matt gates
appears to be
involved in here matt gates approach
basically for the two weeks since this
broke
has been to minimize the seriousness of
the investigation
and to suggest that the investigation is
merely politically motivated and
and nothing else at this point the
investigations
are so wide-ranging they've been going
on for so long and they involve so many
different people
that it would be a very silly way to
carry out a political
hit job against matt gates you wouldn't
do it this way you wouldn't do it in a
way where there's so much
uh involving other people other already
plea deals that
for example joel greenberg already
accepting a plea deal is just not the
way that it would work
this also i think it's important to
mention sheds new light onto the pardon
that matt gates
supposedly asked donald trump for now i
told you last week that
uh donald trump has denied
having been asked for a pardon by matt
gates
although the sourcing on the stories
claiming gates asked for the pardon are
very good
my best explanation for how this could
all be true
as i mentioned earlier this week is that
matt gates has one of his associates
sort of feel out a pardon with
people around donald trump the people
around trump could easily say
gates is not getting a pardon it never
actually gets to trump it never actually
gets to the point of donald trump saying
no it's it's merely made clear between
staffers that it's not going to happen
seems a completely plausible way in
which basically all of the reporting is
true at least in some way
a very possible outcome here
we're all talking about will gates
resign
will he be arrested will he be charged
is gates going to go to prison
with a lot of these got and it is guys
that it happens with
a possible outcome is gates has some
kind of come to jesus moment
he resigns or maybe not but he says he's
entering some kind of
program 12-step who knows sex addicts
anonymous alcoholics anonymous
he's going to work on himself maybe he
doesn't even resign but maybe he does
and then he comes back and says he found
jesus and he's been saved and all of
this stuff it seems completely plausible
to me
that that's the direction it could go of
course everyone is innocent until proven
guilty
matt gates hasn't even been charged at
this point and
i have no you know there's i'll get
emails saying david how how dare you say
gates should go to prison i haven't said
that once
the first step would be let's see if
gates is charged hasn't happened yet
if he is then we will go to the next
step so we are starting to see a bit of
a shift already
among uh individuals who have been
critical of donald trump
starting to go in the direction of if
trump runs i wouldn't run and if trump
runs i would support him the latest is
nikki haley nikki haley former
republican governor of south carolina
she was donald trump's ambassador to the
united nations for a relatively brief
period of time
nikki haley is now saying if trump runs
she would not run and if trump runs she
would support
donald trump just recently she was
critical of trump
saying that trump would be judged
harshly
by history it seemed as though nikki
haley
maybe was starting to be more direct and
forthright
about her reservations about donald
trump and at the time when we reported
that i said
to you i think this is merely posturing
i think this is nikki haley
putting out some sort of very very light
possible critique whether we can even
call it a critique as a question mark
um and she's trying to play both sides
and
uh none of these people spoke out when
trump was still in power
none of them spoke out when they were
still working for donald trump and it
seems that that's exactly what it is
we're going to look at a clip here
here is nikki haley saying uh yeah
if donald trump if donald trump runs she
would support it and she would not run
take a look at this
he still has a lot of popularity if he
runs again in 2024 will you support him
yes if he decides that he's going to run
would that preclude any sort of run that
you would possibly make yourself
i would not run as president trump
friend
and i would talk to him about it you
know that's something that we'll have a
conversation about at some point if
that decision is something that has to
be made but yeah i would absolutely
i had a great working relationship with
him i appreciated the way he let me do
my job
i thought we did some fantastically
great foreign policy
things together and look i just want to
keep building on what we accomplished
and not watching
them when was the last time that you
talked to him
after the election before january 6th or
after
before january
so there it is i think that these this
is
first of all this is significant because
there's lots of people talking about
nikki haley running in 2024 herself
there are many republicans who are it's
nikki haley is not the traditional
republican wing
but she's also also not full cue q anon
she's kind of in the middle
and there are there's a contingent of
the republican party that likes the idea
of nikki haley running for the
republican nomination
and when she so clearly says if trump
runs i won't even try to challenge him
and if trump runs i will i will support
him
that signals to us something about how
the 2024 republican primary would go
if it were held today and that is
exactly the way i've been talking about
it which is
based on republican support for trump
right now
it's trump's if he wants it if trump
fails to play king maker in the 2022
midterms if trump
supports marjorie taylor greene and
lauren bobo bobert
and madison cawthorne and they lose that
steals political capital from donald
trump and if that happens
his fundraising beyond 2022 will likely
be hurt
and if that happens it's not seeming
super likely that donald trump will run
in 2024 but
if it were held today with something
like 80 percent of republican voters
wanting trump involved
uh 60 of republican voters believing
trump won
the november 2020 election it is trump's
for the taking at this point in time let
me know
what other than the success or failure
of trumpian members of congress and the
senate
could determine what trump does in 2024
i think trump's health is always a
question mark i mean he's obese
he's not a healthy guy uh i think that
that that four years from now three and
a half years from now that could be a
factor
uh but let me know what else you think
other than just his popularity we'll
take a quick break
after the break we will have the latest
very strange comments from senator john
kennedy
no relation to the democratic kennedy
family
i also have a voicemail for you some
people are very concerned about
me actually i'll tell you why we'll hear
the latest from mike lindell
and uh much much more stay with us
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at
david patreon.com show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him i don't know if maybe
there's a contest going on
between republican senators who can
appear to be the most disconnected from
the modern world and how we talk about
things in 2021
but if such a contest exists i would
nominate
republican senator john kennedy no
relation
to the democratic kennedy family in the
last month
i brought you the story of senator john
kennedy strangely trying to equate
guns and cars as well as kind of
equating the regulation
of guns and cars you can check out that
segment from the march
24th show if it sounds interesting and
it is actually pretty interesting
but yesterday john kennedy was on fox
news ostensibly talking about i guess
police shootings
and police brutality and he started
talking about how
we quote higher whites blacks
and browns it was as
strange a segment as it sounds let's
take a look
there's no justice we can't have a
society without order
and we have decided to hire law
enforcement officials to maintain
order we hire whites blacks browns
men women to to maintain order
many many of our of our
law enforcement agencies are our
majority minori
if you want to sound like a racist
southerner like if you really want to
play the prototypical caricature of a
racist
american right wing southerner you say
exactly what he said
in exactly that accent exactly how he
talks about
whites blacks and browns that's how you
make yourself look like
the typical uh caricature of a southern
racist american in another moment
from the same appearance senator kennedy
apparently in an effort to push back
against the defund the police movement
which is supported by very few people
he says if you don't like police next
time call a crackhead
that's his word not mine i'll put it
this way if you hate cops just because
they're cops you don't know anything
about them
then next time you get in trouble call a
crackhead
now having said that
what we're really talking about here
what we're talking about here is the
relationship
between crime and race
let's just cut to the chase it is a
statistical fact
that just as it is the case that more
men
than women commit crimes just as it
is a statistical fact that more younger
people than older people commit crimes
we have racial minorities and ethnic
groups in america that have higher crime
rates
we have to why poverty
but that doesn't tell you anything that
is a sitting
united states senator if you can believe
it
this opens up the possibility
of so many skits and satire on saturday
night live
that they must be thanking the comedy
gods right now
if you don't like police call a
crackhead
next time you're in trouble why not just
improve
policing and then feel better about
calling the police
most people don't want to actually
defund or abolish the police
why do you need to go to what we have
or crack heads it's a very strange
kind of backwards reverse
rationalization
the choices are police we don't believe
are as well trained as they should be
and drug addicts like how are those the
parameters that we should be selecting
between
and by the way when i was preparing this
segment
i got a phone call and the clip kept
playing without sound
if you want to see a really a scary
movie so to speak
watch senator uh john kennedy speaking
without the audio on it's really the
stuff of nightmares but that's an aside
now there's like one percent
that john kennedy gets correct here
don't hate police for being police
most police officers are people
who are choosing to be police officers
for admirable
good reasons and who never have
complaints
against them about use of force it would
be bad
it would be a non-thinking reason
to hate an individual officer because
they are a police officer
at the same time and this is where you
know it's almost like they can't hold
two ideas simultaneously at the same
time
you can understand that all
officers can be part of a system
that is not productively serving
a large portion of the people in their
respective communities
and that there are changes there that
need to be made
none of it involves crackheads none of
it involves
drug addicts of any kind now i know that
the caricature is the left just wants to
end police
or defund the police or cancel police or
whatever there are some who want to do
that
most don't we have the public
polling data on it what most people want
is to
reform and restructure the police and i
know that there are some on the left
including in my audience who get mad and
they say
reform has never worked why would it
work now well we've not actually done it
and there are police unions that get in
the way of certain reform
elements that are often recommended and
suggested including a national bad
actors database
that police departments be mandated to
both report to the bad actors database
as well as
to use it for reference when hiring a
new police officer
i have multiple segments with 10 or 12
possible specific reforms
most people just want to improve
policing there are situations
where you don't need an armed officer to
show up there are situations that are
better de-escalated
by social workers and others but we
could also give police officers better
training as social workers that's
another great idea
better equip them for de-escalation in
many countries police are much better
trained
for de-escalation none of it requires
crackheads and none of it requires
defunding or canceling the police costco
has stopped
stalking excuse me my pillow
products my pillow ceo mike lindell
is uh furious about this now if you
don't know who mike lindell is
congratulations you've avoided one of
the most
toxic elements of the last year of the
news
mike lindell is a uh ceo of a company
called mypillow he sells pillows mostly
on right wing tv
and radio at the beginning of the
pandemic he was front
and center because donald trump invited
him to the white house to announce that
he would be
retooling some of his factories to
produce masks rather than pillows
when we tried to actually figure out how
many masks did they really produce
it's unclear but it seems the number is
extraordinarily low
mike lindell at that point started
talking about how trump is a gift from
god to the united states
and generally went completely off the
deep end after the november election
mike lindell was one of the primary
promulgators on newsmax and fox news and
other channels
of completely baseless conspiracy
theories about the election
and uh with all sorts of claims
including recently that donald trump
will be resuming power i believe he said
in august or something like that
so this guy is completely off the rails
and as a result
because we have you know a sort of free
market and businesses can decide what to
do
some retailers have decided to stop
selling my
my pillow pillows and uh
before costco made the decision kroger
had already done the same lindell now
says
at least 22 retailers have stopped
selling
his pillows since january and that
includes
sam's club and kohl's and bed bath and
beyond
mike lindell has also announced that he
will be launching a new online
store to compete against amazon in
reality
it seems that he's launching an online
store to sell the pillows that lots of
retailers aren't selling
he said this the other day because i'm
looking at another thing we're going to
be launching which is my store
which is a rival to amazon pretty uh
pretty explosive stuff right now i have
to tell you
i have never been to a costco in my life
i think you need a membership to shop
there
i've never had one okay between costco
paying better wages than lots of other
retailers
and dropping my pillow this is sounding
like a place
i'm gonna have to investigate maybe i
should be shopping at costco
lindell is blaming costco's decision
on so-called cancel culture this
is actually called when you do things
other things happen
it's a free market everybody gets to
speak
speech can sometimes have consequences
and
not selling someone's pillows is
protected speech it's a business
decision that businesses can make
no one's rights have been violated no
one has had
their membership in a protected class
used
to discriminate against them or to deny
them something
by cancel culture what it really is
are the consequences of a free
enterprise
where people can decide what to say and
what to do
for themselves that's all that this is
and this also gets back to what i said
on monday i believe it was
about people no longer understand
sorry many people no longer understand
or never understood
what counts as a fact and what counts
as an opinion mike lindell isn't getting
dropped
by costco and others for opinions
he's being dropped because he's
spreading demonstrably
false statements about facts we call
those lies
and they are particularly corrosive lies
corrosive to democracy
and corrosive to national stability now
as far as the my pillow user base
i've never met anyone who bought a my
pillow pillow
could anyone really want a pillow so
badly that they would support this guy
or to put it a different way everything
i've read is that the pillows aren't
great but
if the pillows were really really good
with so many pillows out there
and available why would anybody need
this
pillow unless you're just trying to make
a political statement are there any my
pillow customers
who are not politically aligned with
with
mike pillow with mike lindell from
mypillow to me it seems like it's just
politics like if you like mike lindell
and you want to support a right-wing
company you buy his pillow
i would never even think to go and look
for pillows from political actors like
this
uh he could be selling orthopedic shoes
and it would still just be about
politics as far as i can tell if you are
a
leftist who knows mike pillows
i'm not doing that on purpose mike
lindell's uh
politics and still are getting his
pillow
i want to hear from you i want to hear
from you tell me what is so
great about the pillow that you were
ignoring his completely ridiculous
political views let me know we have a
voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p um
i am uh causing concern
among some of our viewers here is
someone who's worried about me take a
listen to this
hi david i just watched and finished
watching your video
right um uh you did an interview with
someone with more
subscribers and uh i couldn't help but
notice uh this wasn't the key takeaway
from the video but
you seem to like be kind of uh pale and
have like
kind of like bags under your eyes i'm
just wondering if
with of your newfound um success on your
on your um channel um maybe you've been
eating
too much magic spoon and it's been
keeping you up at night and you've been
using your
helix matrix more for things like
bluetooth and rest
yeah exactly no so i actually i got so
this is about an interview i did last
week
not from the studio but from the office
and then i received similar emails
this week because i've been broadcasting
from the bunker as we call it
um no it people are used to the way i
look with my studio
lighting and that lighting is very very
powerful and professional and you know
there's six lights in there and
everything's tuned not perfectly but
it's tuned in a particular way
when people all of a sudden see me just
in front of like a white light
with you know a technical setup that's
not as not as properly balanced
including white balance
i often get messages david you're
looking very pale you're looking tired
the you know my real appearance is sort
of like the average of the way i look at
all of the different places i broadcast
from but everything's fine
i'm getting a good sleep i'm uh you know
taking my vitamin d
i'm doing all of my stuff everything's
fine i appreciate the concern but
absolutely no need to worry just
different lighting makes
i also got another one saying my voice
sounded strained this week
i'm just using a different mic it just
sounds different it's just tuned a
little bit differently
the uh elements of audio are just
slightly slightly different than in the
studio so all is well and i appreciate
the concern
on today's bonus show
ted cruz and josh hawley two republican
senators
suddenly they want to break up major
league baseball
is it because they've suddenly found
that we are not enforcing
antitrust law that is already on the
books
no it's just political they don't like
that major league baseball has protested
georgia voting restrictions
so they want to break up major league
baseball secondly
canada is doing a great job of reducing
poverty
and increasing equality we will talk
about how
they are doing it and lastly
we should be bracing for higher grocery
bills
for the rest of the year why
and how much more expensive we will talk
about
exactly that on today's
bonus show you can get instant access to
the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
you can use the coupon code if you want
the coupon code is better21 and it will
save you
a bundle on a membership and also
finally it looks as though joe biden's
non-state of the union
state of the union has been scheduled
nancy pelosi sent a letter to joe biden
yesterday inviting him
to address a joint session of the house
and senate
on wednesday april 28th that's going to
be a big night we will be
live live live on youtube
twitch facebook we may even be live on
other platforms by then so
uh mark that on the calendar we will be
live on uh two weeks from today joe
biden will be doing his
it's not called the state of the union
it will be a joint address to the senate
and the house
that will be two weeks from today i'll
see you on the bonus show
i'll see you on the live stream and
we'll be back also of course
with a new show tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary shower head
that saves you money by using 45 percent
less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman